comment ça va francis ceva toit très
bien passé une bonne soirée si tout va
bien jusque là donc francis lalanne vous
êtes poète écrivain chanteur compositeur
acteur réalisateur producteur
souffleur de verre éditeurs chef
d'entreprise c'est vrai et on raconte on
ne sait pas si c'est vrai que vous allez
partir en irak pour devenir boucliers
humains à bagdad non sérieux c'est vrai
ça me fait rire toute l'histoire de la
guerre en irak
non tu aurais vu avec madelin on voit
bien que ça me faisait pareil alors
c'est quand ce départ ben écoute c'est
pas prévu au programme non mais en
revanche j'ai ouvert un email je peux
donner mon email bien sûr alors cl d'eau
in 2002 ldw yens 2 milles attaché en
majuscules aldrin de bellouet hathaway
hell.com
elam écrivent tous les gens qui sont
pour que chirac met le veto au conseil
de sécurité dont ils mettent oui pour
lever tôt leurs noms et leurs adresses
sont en train de faire une pétition
comme ça d'accord pas mal déjà bah oui
c'est très bien vraiment les poissons
et puis basta ya
pense pas partir
pas pour l'instant non mais pourquoi tu
vas tu irais s'il fallait peut-être oui
je crois que je n'avais pas encore pensé
mais pourquoi pas une idée déjà je
m'occupe de ma pétition parce que je me
dis si on est quelques millions sur
cette pétition ça peut peut-être faire
réfléchir
alors aujourd'hui c'est le chanteur que
nous recevons enfin du chanteur l'auteur
compositeur chanteur 1 le nouvel album
14 chansons paroles et musique
et donc
ça roll music 14 chansons francis
lalanne sérieux vous n'êtes pas fait
aider par des parts d'autres gens il y
en avait 30 au départ ma maison de
disques on a choisi 14 et comment ils
ont retenu les 14 et qu'ils ont viré
laisser autre c'est un mystère
c'est la fin c'est leur choix oui voilà
et vous les laisser faire oui
oui parce que moi ça m'intéresse pas de
choisir les chansons ça me plaît de les
écrire d enregistrer voilà et puis mon à
un moment donné je fais confiance à
l'équipe qui bosse avec moi et qui sait
collectif c'est un disque c'est une
oeuvre collective c'est comme un film
l'album s'appelle d'une vie à l'autre
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui mais je trouve très courageux
francis parce qu'il a les caméras de
télé toute la journée chez lui et le
soir il pourra changer d idée
là
c'est le chanteur auteur compositeur que
nous que nous recevons ce soir votre
plus gros succès si on se retrouvera le
la bande originale de rossi le passage
par dont la bande originale du film le
marché s'assainit son sort ouais ça
c'était comment dois je me suis un peu
penser à moi comme je t'aime
et tu me délivrera
tu brisera l'anathème
kim tien
de tes bras
ah ben ça moi comme je t'aime
rien
je ne sais pas
à même pas les chrysanthèmes
tu verras on se
je trouve
ce sens
silvera me
évidemment plus pouvoir a raison on
aurait pu vous recevoir comme loft
heures je vous êtes le héros avec joey
starr de cheveux 60 jours 60 nuits comme
membre éminent des grosses têtes de
philippe bouvard ou tard est aussi voilà
mais dans lesquels j'ai passé des
moments merveilleux pendant bien des
années alors avant le démarrage de cette
série sur canal + 60 jours 60 nuits vous
avez déclaré je suis fier de faire
partie de cette aventure qui va
révolutionner la télévision française
cette femme arrête toi ça me fait marrer
oui parce qu'aujourd'hui ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de savoir ce que vous
déclarez aujourd'hui après la
catastrophe qu'a été ce programme moi je
trouve que ce programme il révolutionne
les choses parce qu'il est il crée un
nouveau genre un genre où se marient la
fiction et la réalité et je trouve que
c'est intéressant voilà et alors
l'émission en question en 60 jours 60
nuits est en boîte depuis le 2 février
donc ce qui va passer jusqu'au 1er mars
est déjà enregistrée alors que
l'émission c'est censé être finalement
votre vie quotidienne donc c'est bidon
non ces familles dont il ya un mois de
décalage entre le tournage et la
diffusion à d'accord mais tous les gens
qui ont regardé la télé quand quand il
était à peu près au aux chais pas moi au
10 janvier et qu'il voyait que c'était
noël ils ont compris qu'avec un décalage
la diffusion et le braconnage tu vois
alors est ce que c'est vrai que votre
appartement été redécorée pour les pour
les raisons de l'émission
mon appartement il a été redécoré c'est
à dire qu'il ya eu si tu veux comme il y
avait un tournage de prévu il a fallu
faire des ouvertures à droite à gauche
pour que les caméras puissent circuler
c'est tout voilà ouais je pose les
questions tu réponds voilà tu te marche
pas il ne s'agira pas du tout la
personne se marre
la dernière fois qu'on s'est vus francis
lalanne c'était pour parler des bleus et
on parlait de christian 42 voilà
christian karembeu et puis ensuite vous
êtes devenu le président des supporteurs
au mondial en corée mais vous qui étiez
en corée vous savez pourquoi ils ont
perdu
ils ont perdu parce qu'ils n'ont pas
gagné oui non mais des raisons quand
même ben c'est le football ça c'est le
football je dire
dans le sport ce qui est extraordinaire
dans le sport de manière générale c'est
que c'est pas le plus fort qui gagne
c'est le meilleur et le meilleur c'est
pas forcément le plus fort c'est celui
qui a trouvé les ressources nécessaires
pendant pendant le match pendant la
partie pendant la performance pour
surpasser son adversaire c'est vrai
qu'il y avait un hôtel où il y avait un
ascenseur qui descendait directement
dans la boîte de nuit non c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai sanaa dans les mecs ils
ont bossé ils ont dormi en fait ce
qu'ils ont pu ils ont perdu ouais ouais
ça arrive
est-ce que vous êtes prêts francis
lalanne pour une interview champion du
monde ou champion de france y'a pas de
problème
[Applaudissements]
francis lalanne au niveau des drogues
douces est ce que vous êtes plutôt
champion du monde ou champion de france
je sais pas ce que c'est que la drogue
douce ou de viol il ya de la drogue quoi
ou y aller les choses auxquelles on est
accro quoi voilà et on est tourné tous
accros à quelque chose à l'air qu'on
respire donc comment un général quand
j'aime quelque chose je suis comme chez
une nature extrême et je vais toujours
au bout des choses je pense que je
serais plutôt
dans une compétition mondiale que dans
une compétition nationale un haut niveau
un mot vous êtes plutôt champion du
monde champion de france
j'aime et mais
d'une manière générale dont capitaine au
niveau pétage de plombs vous êtes plutôt
champion du monde fut champion de france
l'applaudimètre je crois je suis
champion du monde
dernière question au niveau prise de
tête êtes champion du monde ou champion
de france dans ses émissions il m'arrive
d'être champion du monde
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux